[Applause]
I was married for seventeen and a half
years I've been divorced for about 12
years now we're driving home and he just
turned around and said I don't want to
be married anymore I was around 14 years
old when my parents told me that my dad
was leaving I was devastated only
because I got married to be married only
once so I felt like I failed I never
gave up on ever wanting to get married
but the divorce has really affected me
as a person and has affected me in my
relationships you know as a mother I
don't want her to have any kind of pain
and that's gonna happen that's just life
it's still a work in progress for sure I
I think everything should be looked upon
with love and I think that you guys
really love each other and that's ahead
of how I started because I just think
your father was a little too young to
really love the way it was needed he's
now in a good place and he's he knows
what love is now right hmm even though
it wasn't with me and I know that hurts
but you know what when you love somebody
it's okay to see them happy yeah that's
important respect that's one of the
things your grandmother told me on our
wedding day she said if you cross that
line of respect it's easy to go and do
it again yeah do it again and then you
get further
you can confer them you're comfortable
with it and then it gets ugly sense of
humor I think we'll never survive if we
didn't laugh a whole lot of course
sometimes I say stuff that is just that
awful to watch this dimension and I yell
back you know how tables turn in between
all those things it sounds hokey because
a lot of people are gonna say oh that's
hokey it's not hokey if you don't love
somebody you can't put up with their
caca
so if you love each other you'll put up
with a lot of stuff and you'll have the
patience patience is another one
patience you have patience my darling
you have patience like I will never have
but but don't shove everything under the
rug we used to do that you know we
finally told your grandparents that we
were gonna get divorced they don't like
but you guys never fight we've never
seen you argue and we've never seen
their upsetness it's healthy as long as
you don't get nasty but it's healthy
because children need to know that
there's conflict and there's resolution
yeah and I don't use I'm sorry lightly
when we fight we say I'm sorry I'm sorry
just to shut somebody up and that's not
you have to use those words when you
really mean that you're not going to do
it again or you're gonna be very
conscious of not doing something mom so
what do you think is the best part about
being married the best part about being
married is having a partner through
thick through thin when you just want to
watch movies when you want to go out
when you want to laugh when you want to
cry it's important you know to have
buddy you know I missed that cold one
what's the hardest part listening yeah I
think we've talked about that a lot
listening is really important even
though I want to get my point across I
have trouble communicating what I'm
really feeling and I don't wanna ruffle
the feathers well that's one of the
attributes you got from your father you
didn't get it from me if you feel like
you're going to say something that's
going to hurt or you're trying to be I
need to like get them right now is best
to like say you know why we're arguing
right now but I really really love you
I love you so much but I really don't
like you right now don't like you I love
him that's really important from the
divorce I understood and was able to see
how incredibly strong you are to see you
come out of it it was the best thing
because I was like my mom is like
literally the strongest person I know
yeah and you guys mean so much to me
that's sitting across and breaking bread
with your father and his wife and the
family now the wedding coming up that I
can do it without ill feeling they will
come in and I will have my arms wide
open what I'm most excited for that day
I think the most exciting moment will be
standing at the end of the aisle seeing
David
at the other end probably very emotional
but that just like moment I'm looking
forward to and then overall just finally
getting to
know that he and I are gonna spend
forever together and where I get to love
respect love and listen love and have a
sense of humor love and patience you
make me extremely proud you're an
amazing young woman they're smart you're
loving you're kind
[Music]